hey y'all it's time for a new episode of
the wine down this week we're discussing
low-keyed I'm East episode 2 so this
episode has a lot of ISA trying to
figure out obviously a lot of things
post black parties yes why do you think
ISA is being so stubborn about reaching
out to Molly after what happened Babur
and the question series Ethan is always
reaching out to do a gesture apologize
to Molly but then someone said because
she always but I think this time is
different it's just like when you're in
these situations when you're fresh off
of right you are thinking about the
tallied history of issues and the reach
out and things like that and I feel like
ISA feels particularly wrong do you know
Molly's words are echoing in her head
about being a user and I think she just
wants the olive branch extended for once
in their friendship um take flame I
think it'd be one thing if they had that
fight at home even if the chaos hadn't
happened post a block party you know
even if they had Collins itself down and
mommy just walked off you say it you say
you saw me struggling that we got shot
like this is a combination of all this
hard work do we have to do this here do
we have do this right now and then the
next day the comments about the block
party I thought I guess is just stewing
on those things and it's like you
embarrass me at my thing
yeah absolutely why do you feel this was
the right moment in time to meet ESA's
mob you know and what is he sort of
learned from her in watching shows I
personally have never been interested in
the parental backstory and unless there
was a reason and it felt like ISA so
isolated at this time she's lost the
core friendship in her life and I felt
like there's something about going back
to her roots and trying to figure out
like am i use a word of this come from
sometimes you just you don't know where
else to go sometimes we just need your
mom and she doesn't realize like how sad
she is how much she's holding on to this
and moms always know and I think ISA is
relying on that it's just like my mom
knows my mom knows the right things to
say he's are supposed to do this
self-care Sunday binder so why do you
think she decides to go
the paint and sip with these girls as
opposed to continuing to take care of
herself
I think usually I'm gonna just drink I'm
gonna paint some cactus my looking dicks
and just like the other one has some fun
they think that she's like she sees them
as her energy booze and they basically
just like you know how many gasps you
love they brought to me yeah my friends
so he's not leave she walked out the
opportunity to talk to mommy she takes a
sign of seeing Molly to walk away from
her do you think that pieces done with
her friendship for Molly for good hmm I
think as we talked about in the show is
like you know are these friendships for
you know seasonal or reasonable right
and I think that moment brings up a
whole other level of life when she's
really gonna hit me killing me
I don't think he said what's that smoke
but I definitely Easton was gonna hold
it there like she was gone she was gonna
bark like she was gonna wanted I also
don't think it helps that after
beginning the episode Ethan wants to be
reached out to you know she's just like
I'm tired of reaching out and she walks
up sees her friend in her favorite
restaurant sitting there on her phone
sugar like you have your phone and
you're not using it to reach out to me
yep so I know for me that would sugar me
I'm sitting up here worrying about you
all day and you know trying to take care
of myself and wondering if each text is
from you and your yeah I mean her
words of echoing in your ears yeah give
you the episode and I think the fact
that she's on her phone at getting food
like it's just like a regular day so
you for another episode of no wine
down
[Applause]
you